Here we have two hypothetical amino acids.
We recognize the hallmarks of amino acids.
We have an amino group at this end,
which gives us the "amino" part of the amino acid.
We have a carboxyl group at the other end.
This is the acidic part of the amino acid.
Among them we have a carbon atom,
which is called alpha carbon.
This alpha carbon is connected
with a hydrogen atom and some kind of side chain.
We will call this side chain R1,
and this side chain R2.
We will look into this video
how two amino acids
form a peptide bond to each other.
I remind you that the peptide is simple
chain of amino acids.
How from these two amino acids
we can form a dipeptide.
The dipeptide contains two amino acids.
This is the smallest possible peptide,
but we can continue to add amino acids to it
and get a polypeptide.
In short,
this nitrogen atom uses its free electron pair,
to form a bond with the carbon atom of the carbonyl group here.
This free electron pair and the carbon atom of the carbonyl group
form a bond and then this hydrogen atom,
this hydrogen atom and this oxygen atom can together
to form a water molecule.
The molecule of water is separated from these two amino acids.
We get this reaction
bond between nitrogen and carbon atom
and releasing a water molecule.
Since we have a molecule of water,
this type of reaction, as we have seen before
with other types of molecules,
is called condensation
or dehydration.
Condensation,
condensation reaction
or dehydration.
We saw this type of reaction,
when we linked glucose molecules to each other,
when we got carbohydrates.
Dehydration.
Whenever you see a reaction like this,
it is very satisfying to be able to
to calculate and say, "So, this will be related to this,"
"we see the connection here"
"I will get rid of an oxygen atom and two hydrogen atoms,"
"which collectively equals H2O, the molecule of water."
How can we imagine the mechanism of the reaction?
Can we displace electrons?
Can we explain a little organic chemistry,
to understand how the reaction actually takes place?
I will do this now.
I will not go into much detail about the mechanism of the reaction,
but I'll just explain what's going on.
As we have said, the nitrogen atom has one free electron pair,
it is electronegative.
And this carbon atom here is connected
with two oxygen atoms, they are more electronegative.
Oxygen atoms can attract electrons.
And this nitrogen atom may want to do
something known in organic chemistry as a nucleophilic reaction,
with this carbon atom here.
When this happens,
if we explain the mechanism more carefully,
we can say, "Hey, maybe one
"of these double bonds is dropped,"
"her electrons return to oxygen"
"and then the oxygen gets a negative charge."
But this free electronic pair
may form the double bond again.
When this happened,
this oxygen atom in the hydroxyl group accepts
these two electrons.
He accepts the two electrons
and now has an additional free e-pair.
Let me delete this link
and give the oxygen another free electron pair.
There are already two free couples,
and when he accepts the electrons from this connection,
there will be a third free e-pair.
And there will be a negative charge.
Now you can guess,
that he will snatch a hydrogen proton from somewhere.
It can accept any hydrogen proton,
but perhaps the most comfortable one would be here,
because if the nitrogen atom uses its free electron pair,
to form a bond with the carbon atom,
he will have a positive charge
and can accept these electrons.
You can imagine that when one
of these free pairs is used to bind to this hydrogen proton,
the nitrogen atom can accept these electrons,
to take these electrons back.
I hope this was not too confused,
but I always love to ask,
what can actually happen here?
And as you can see, the free electron pair
of the nitrogen atom forms this orange bond with the carbon atom.
Let me paint it in orange,
if I call it an orange connection.
This orange connection is formed.
This orange tie
is called a peptide bond, peptide binding.
Peptide bond
or
peptide coupling.
Then we have a molecule of water.
This oxygen atom is one,
you can assume that this hydrogen atom is one,
and this hydrogen atom is here,
generally equate to a water molecule.
When I first saw this reaction,
you are polysmith, "Yes, it seems logical."
But under physiological conditions,
amino acids are not in this form.
Physiological pH is more likely
to discover this form of amino acids,
to discover them as bulls.
Zwitterions. Let me write it.
A fun word for pronouncement.
One word is, but I will write both of her parts
in different colors to see them.
Zweeterion.
What does this mean?
Zwitter in German means hybrid.
The hybrid ion
is an ion which has a charge in its distal ends,
parts of the molecule have a charge,
but when you collect them, it becomes neutral.
The parts are loaded, but the whole is neutral.
At a physiological pH, the amino portion,
the portion of the amino acid containing nitrogen
grabs an additional proton and gets a positive charge,
and the carboxyl group yields one proton
and becomes negatively charged.
This will be consistent with
the forms we saw at the beginning,
but at physiological pH, amino acids are more common
such as zwitterions.
How do we get a peptide bond
of this form of amino acids?
You can imagine that this atom here,
after giving his hydrogen proton, has an additional electronic pair.
There are one, two free electronic pairs,
will color the additional electronic pair
in purple.
There is an additional free e-pair.
Can use the extra electronic pair,
to grab a proton from the solution
or to be more comfortable, we can say,
"Maybe he meets the right proton,"
"this one, and cheers on the nitrogen atom"
"to accept these electrons."
If this happens,
when we look at this carboxyl group
and this amino group,
we come to the form we saw at the beginning.
If this atom gets hydrogen,
we will get a hydroxyl group,
if this nitrogen atom receives two electrons,
from this bond, NH2 will be obtained.
So at least that part of the molecules
it will be just like the ones we started with.
Now you can imagine how we get there
to peptide coupling,
what we have here.
This is the peptide bond.
Then the only difference between the resulting peptide
in this reaction,
and the previous one is,
that this is a zwolle.
The form of zwitterion in which the carboxyl group
has given a proton in the solution,
and here the nitrogen
has taken a proton from the solution,
so the total charge is neutral,
although the two ends of the molecule are loaded.
I hope you were fun.